um are you
actively looking for new hosts or is
that something where you kind of it's
weird because yes but a lot of times the
economics of it are a little hard to
wrap your head around I think people
think that like what we do just prints a
[__] ton of money like and it's like
well it's really not the case and I know
people that have started basically like
clones of my business and then seem to
have like a reality check at some point
and be like oh so we're not going to
make any money and this is going to be
really really [__] difficult um but
yeah like I um what the [__] were you
saying oh yeah okay so like the math in
my head is like it would be great to put
together another at the end of the day
but I mean what are you going to like
especially a lot of the people that I
would like to put together in one of
these types of podcasts I would have to
like move them to La okay okay so right
there let's say that you got to pay
somebody if they're going to be doing
multiple podcasts per week or whatever
what do you got to pay them like [__]
8 10 grand a month that type of [__]
move somebody to town yeah cuz most
people aren't going to leave their
Hometown unless it's a unless to survive
in a place like La exactly if I say hey
I'll give you 5 grand a month to move
out here I mean that's going to pay for
their rent and some food or whatever
like and if they're like a host like a
on camera Talent who probably has other
opportunities or could just do YouTube
on their own then that doesn't sound
that appealing so you got to let's say
have to pay everybody 10 grand let's say
I got to pay 10 grand a month to three
different people now you got to figure
out how you're going to make $30,000 a
month it's not easy off a podcast you're
going to have you're going to have to
really kill it with the sponsors and
you're going to have to have them like
be really in the zone the podcast is
really going to have to have like a
hardcore fandom I think I could probably
do it and hopefully we do end up taking
that sort of Step this year but it also
might rely kind of on like oh we might
have to like really push the patreon
ankle you you know that type of thing
like maybe if we can cuz if you make a
piece of content that people like are
really signing up for the patreon to see
bonus content or whatever now it's
starts to make sense outside of the
sponsors and the ads um but it's really
you guys do so much content because
there's no jumper news every day yeah
Monday through Friday yeah so it's like
a Monday through Friday thing with
usually three
hosts right usually there's three more
but yeah I mean so yeah I mean that's
you're I mean yeah that's already like
its own thing but that's good because it
gives us a way to test out Talent try
people without having throw people in do
you guys repurpose that for a news
channel on Snapchat yeah okay that makes
sense so it makes a little bit more
money that way yeah yeah the Snapchat
thing's lit so thank you for that
brother thank you no doubt Snapchat's
great people don't know and then I
realized now that I like know that
Snapchat shows are a thing I'll be like
yo the most random people have Snapchat
shows and a lot of the Snapchat shows
are like their old YouTube videos from
2017 repurposed repurposed yeah that's
what people who make like Evergreen
content like the professor uh the
basketball dude like he told me that his
Facebook is his biggest Revenue stream
but he makes content that you could see
it six years after he filmed it still
doesn't old so just hooping even Logan
Paul told me he makes crazy amount of
money on Facebook and it's like he's
posting his Vlogs doing [__] that would
never that he would never do now he's
just putting it on Facebook and it still
works you know how's your relationship
these days with a uh we talk pretty good
amount yeah I feel like you guys have an
interesting uh on camera Dynamic where
you know he's obviously cool with ad and
those guys and right but he he's you
know he's obviously a Trailblazer during
during the uh the streaming era if you
will It's Kind of a Funny uh switch
between us because he was kind of like
getting involved uh when ad and trell
were all them were all there and stuff
and there was a couple times where he
said something like oh like ad you
should be getting paid uh 200 Grand a
year at no jumper right and that's like
obviously he wasn't so he's kind of like
like like and he's saying like I would
pay you guys this amount now you like
Fast Forward to like he's really pushing
the academy thing and trying to like
build up his cast and everything and I'm
sure he's he's probably going through
some of the growing pains you had to go
I'm sure he's aware that it would be
difficult for him to pay any of those
host $220,000 a month or whatever so I
think uh he's he's realizing the same
thing that I kind of realized which is
that the whole business model of like
I'm going to pay a bunch of people to
just make content on behalf of my brand
I mean it didn't work for complex like
they they weren't profitable with Joe
Bon and it does work for a lot of people
man it didn't work for Revolt state of
the culture never went anywhere and
you're talking about like big budgets
big names and meanwhile with like no
jumper it's like well we don't have as
big of a budget we can't afford to just
lose money for this long ass period of
time sponsors don't often times want to
touch this uh sort of edgy content with
violence being disgust and sex being
disgusting God knows what so hey shout
out to our sponsor King pal who's also a
sponsor of no jumper King pom water it's
good water chug it it's good water
That's My slogan I made up for them no
but like uh yeah King pal is is dope but
um I just don't have a lot of belief
like I used to always say about no
jumper like no jumper needs to be a
network we're going to have all these
hosts and they're going to do content
and y y and like we achieved that for a
while but the finances were kind of
wonky and I didn't really have my
business down the way that I should have
because I should have had contracts that
kind of prohibited a lot of the stuff
that ended up happening and by the time
that stuff happened and they were
talking about no jumber drama on their
streams every day it was like already
kind of far gone and I realized that I
didn't really there wasn't really a way
for me to reverse time and get back to
what I thought that the situation should
be but when I look at all these other uh
podcasts and platforms and stuff I don't
see really most of them having much
success with it either I mean you have
somebody like Joe and I think he largely
survives off patreon you know yeah he's
gone I mean he's gone through it with
trying to launch a network I mean
publicly he had a couple different shows
on there that didn't work out and
everything so I don't have a ton of
faith in that like obviously we we do
have like brick and sharp and they're
still doing content on no jumper and
stuff like that but it's definitely a
tricky business to be in and I wouldn't
tr's in La now right yeah yeah I
wouldn't say I'm like really devoted to
like I have to find these hosts and I
have to build up more podcast because
the business side of it is just hard
what was for you was it like obviously
it has to make sense for you financially
to try to recreate the magic on Melrose
and open a store yeah I mean I just miss
having that sort of spontaneity of just
having a spot and being able to do a you
just shot content there right I just I
think I just saw yeah I just do podcast
there some of the time like last uh well
last week Friday I went there and did
two interviews uh throughout the day at
the spot and then Sunday I came back in
hung out on the Block did two more
interviews on on the Block so I like uh
just being able to be I just like a
certain energy to be on Melrose and
we're right next door to D dub and it is
different than it was before because
there's just like a little bit less hype
around everything but I mean we get to
inherit a lot of the hype that's kind of
going on with dub right there so every
time I'm out there on a Sunday and
there's like a million people just
standing out on the street feels very
good to have like a real Community
around us and everything like that so I
felt like it was important for us to
lean into that and I feel like we get
enough content through being out there
that it's it's it's just good like Remo
would be like there having different
artists come in just to film Tik toks
and take photos and get some merch and
stuff like that and that [__] just kind
of helps the brand like I always loved
having the store on Melrose it's kind of
a shame we gone for three years but I
mean [__] I mean you think about that
Jake home you had that was [__] crazy
and he just walked in right I like just
anything spontaneous is really great for
the content yeah 100% man well listen go
uh subscribe to plug talk the SC only
plug talk.com how much is that scene uh
I'm not exactly sure it's $5 a month to
sign up for plug talk and then that
scene is available in the DMS is that
the business model of only fans pretty
much I've not actually legit never done
the well that's surprising to hear the
sign up thing now that's one thing is
that almost every porn girl has
like you have to pay for like any decent
content on their so like is the main
page just like a normal like feed it
just like like a like a trailer on ours
you get every episode we've ever done
just for the basic monthly amount but on
most girls uh only fans you pay x amount
of dollars and you get like some photos
on the feed and then you got to pay five
bucks 10 bucks whatever it is for
additional content take eight off the
dude yeah there you go yeah damn that so
I really thought he was a s and he was
just lying cuz I didn't watch interview
I just saw the headline so I just
assumed oh he's trying to get out of it
CU he's probably getting clowned by his
homies it's funny that a lot of people
had that reaction but he's full of [__]
yeah but knowing him I don't no no so
yeah I mean now that I kind of know all
the I feel bad for him though because
him now I'm not going to interview him
yeah him coming on no jumper ruined
every other opportunity that he had to
go on all these other podcasts like he
texted me this morning telling me that
he spent $3,000 flying to Miami and then
fresh and they canceled on him and they
were going to pay I just got paid for my
first interview have you got pay to do
an
interview oh Vlad Vlad pays you well but
like we we do like a swap I don't even
ask him anymore but there was a couple
times that he gave me some money just
shout to Vlad man but he pays like a
decent amount he he he takes credit for
that that he started the practice of
paying guests yeah I'm not think that
practice ever comeing come into fruition
here yeah I mean it's nice to get
everything just based in your
relationships but at the end of the day
it's like if you can spend five grand
and make 10 I really honestly would have
paid crit Ma just to just to hang out
with him yeah cuz my son my bro my my
son's best friend shout out to Joe Pete
he born and raised in from 55th Street
born and raised in Burbank but he's from
55th Street there should be a 55th
Street all he on [__] and I'm like bro
shut the [__] up you little [__]
Italian bastard from Burbank you're not
but I was like yo if I pay KP maack I'm
bringing all the kids from burough High
to come in [__] all my son's friend
group will be bring him to the school do
a little meet and greet I don't know if
I could do that you can try get in
trouble for that well like I appreciate
you pulling up always bro Adam 22 boom
fire